rapide malgré le banik le pouls la danse
corrected venez s'il vous plaît cabine
numéro un et vous monsieur jimmy vous
occupez vous êtes gloria france massage
bonjour jimmy alors aux médias le
profiter un peu de neige l'autre aux
deux années j'ai l'impression d'avoir un
homme et comme je suis trapéziste blanc
je me déshabille jusqu'à la ceinture
seulement on pourra pas non plus
aujourd'hui à moi aussi je me disais
mais qu'est ce qui te fais mon petit
poussin
bon ben là allongé vous réserve la voilà
pourquoi me suis mis et merci y'a pas de
quoi j'ai une faille épuisé
ah non moi j'arrête alors ne veulent pas
comme ça je n'ai jusqu'ici je suis
rentré chez moi retrouver ma femme mon
foyer un peu de tranquillité
complètement solim